un homme le président
merci monsieur le président tout d'abord
je voudrais remercier les présidents de
beauf qui or qui ont accepté que je
prenne la parole maintenant avant les
orateurs de la coupe monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en 2020
nous avions du mal à croire à une
seconde vague mais nous voilà début 2022
en pleine pandémie et d'autres peuples
fait face avec courage mais aussi
lassitude et résignation
oui il faut lutter frontalement contre
l'épidémie oui il faut vacciner et
protéger la population mais deux ans
après le début de l'épidémie bout ne
pouvait plus dissimuler la réalité c'est
l'insuffisance de moyens de la santé
publique qui pousse à la mise en oeuvre
de politiques autoritaires de
contraintes qui porte lourdement
atteinte aux libertés publiques
c'est l'hôpital public la médecine de
ville mais aussi l'assurance maladie qui
sont défaillants non pas du fait d'un
personnel qui est exemplaire de
dévouement et de courage mais du fait
des choix libéraux de ces dernières
années maintenu malgré la pro b ni par
emmanuel macron et votre gouvernement
alors nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
votre stratégie de rideau de fumée vous
masquez des mesures par des mesures
coercitives comme le pass sanitaire puis
le pass vaccinale pas départ mais pas
d'urgence permanent l'incurie d'un
système qui a ravalé la santé au rang de
marchandises je le souligne d'emblée si
le passe à nice terre si le pet
sanitaire a boosté la vaccination force
est de constater qu'il n'a pas ralenti
la propagation du virus pour preuve
trois cent mille personnes sont testés
positifs par jour quelle est donc
l'utilité de ces sésames ce rideau de
fumée c'est aussi l'aggravation verbal
du président de la république autres des
millions de personnes non vaccinées dont
beaucoup ne le sont pas par choix mais
par éloignement faiblesse ou
incompréhension quelle est cette france
où l'on sonde les gens pour savoir si
les soins doit toujours être accordée à
ceux qui refusent le vaccin oui
vous fabriquez des parias pour détourner
le débat et nous dénonçons ce jeu
dangereux nous proposerons par voie
d'amendement et cela en préalable à la
discussion du texte que l'entrée en
vigueur du pass vaccinale soit
conditionnée à la remise par le
gouvernement au parlement d'un rapport
sur l'impact et sur le recul de la
propagation de l'épidémie de kobe de 19
car si comme je les dis se passe a pu
être utile faute de politique de santé
publique efficace pour inciter à la
vaccination l'on peut aujourd'hui se
demander ce qui légitime sa prolongation
et son durcissement
instrument auquel s'ajoute celui d'un
traçage numérique étatique banalisée qui
tend lui même à s'amplifier se durcir
comme le propose article 2 du texte en
étendant l'accent l'accès aux données
personnelles médicales aux services
préfectoraux il est temps de mettre fin
ce système de passes inutiles sur le
plan sanitaire et dangereuse sur le plan
des libertés publiques bien d'autres
solutions sont possibles des solutions
d'ordre véritablement sanitaires et non
sécuritaire comme l'accentuation des
gestes barrières et des moyens de lutter
contre la prorogation le déploiement des
tours et détours hi-fi catr d'air la
distribution des masques ffp2
l'effectivité du recours au télétravail
lorsque cela est possible ou encore
l'organisation de roulement dans les
entreprises dans les établissements
scolaires par exemple plus globalement
il s'agirait comme nous vous avons eu
nous avons de celle de le soutenir
d'investir davantage dans la médecine de
ville et la médecine scolaire et de
réarmer l'hôpital public en bref des
mesures pratiques qui répondent à la
crise sanitaire en souhaitant protéger
nos concitoyens et non les punir enfin
il ne s'agit pas d'une épidémie mais
bien d'une pandémie la question est donc
mondiale est la seule réponse efficace
sera de cet ordre c'est pourquoi je le
redis encore il est plus urgent que
jamais de lever les brevets sur les
vaccins pour éviter l'émergence de
nouveaux variants seuls 50 % de la
population mondiale est vaccinée un plan
de vaccination massive dans le monde
doit être déployée plutôt que de taper
sur le point du poing sur la table en
insultant toute une partie de nos
concitoyens
emmanuel macron aurait tout intérêt à
profiter de la présidence française de
l'union européenne pour convoquer un
sommet international et engagé un bras
de fer salutaire autour de la levée des
brevets sur les vaccins et d'un
gigantesque et ford aide au
développement en france nous avons
débloqué des centaines de milliards pour
l'économie combien pour la chanter
combien pour la solidarité
internationale
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
vous en conviendrez nous sommes prêts à
être force de proposition et à débattre
des mesures propres à gérer la crise
sanitaire mais pour l'heure malgré les
tentatives du rapporteur de la
commission des lois pour atténuer
certaines mesures nous nous opposons à
cette énième projet de loi sécuritaire
et d'intimidation d'infantilisation de
nos concitoyens et de
déresponsabilisation
déresponsabilisation de nos dirigeants
emmanuel macron le 12 mars 2020 a
annoncé extraire la santé de la loi du
marché en lutte et aujourd'hui payer un
autre pape dans son quotidien par des
décisions solitaire le refus de
s'attaquer aux dogmes libéraux qui
étouffe l'hôpital la santé et notre pays
nous refusons cette impasse sanitaires
mais aussi démocratique merci madame le
président
[Musique]